good afternoon everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so we are rounding out another big
week here at the White House and a lot
of great news for the American people
the president traveled to Arizona
underscoring how his economic plan
continues to create jobs Revitalize
American manufacturing strengthen our
supply traits and give families more
breathing room for the first time in
almost two years the national average
gas price is lower than its level was
one year ago
Senator Warnock will continue
representing the people of Georgia he
ran on the president's message we must
strengthen Social Security and Medicare
lower prescription drug costs and
protect a woman's right to make her
health care decision
the president announced historic relief
to protect the hard-earned pensions of
hundreds of thousands of union workers
and retirees thanks to the American
Rescue plan
and yesterday President Biden kept his
promise to bring Brittany Greiner home
and reiterated his commitment to
securing Paul Whelan's release the
president will never give up
as Russia continues to wage its brutal
war against people of Ukraine today the
Biden Harris Administration is
announcing a new 275 million dollar
security assistant package to help
Ukraine defend itself against Russian
aggression this package will provide
Ukraine with new capabilities to boost
its to boost its air defenses and
counter the threats Ukraine is facing
from Iranian uavs which Russia is using
to attack Ukraine's critical and
infrastructure and kill Ukrainian
civilians today's announcements also
includes critical equipment that Ukraine
is using so effectively to defend itself
on the battlefield such as more
ammunition for high Mars and Ukraine's
artillery
and now our favorite thing is the week
ahead so just giving you a quick look
actually is more than a quick look we
have a lot to share for next week on
Monday the president and first lady will
travel to Joint Base Meyer Henderson
Hall in Arlington Virginia to
participate in a United States Marine
Corps Reserve Toys for Tots event
they will join spouses of senior
Department of Defense and leaders and
service leadership and local military
children in sorting donated toys for
distribution to families in need ahead
of the holidays this engagement is part
of the the first lady's joining forces
initiative to support those who serve
including families of service members
and Veterans caregivers and survivors
and he'll will also have National
Security advisor Jake Sullivan right
here in the Press briefing room on
Monday to preview the African leaders
Summit on Tuesday the president will
host a ceremony on the south lawn to
sign the respect for Marriage Act
accompanied by members of Congress
members of his cabinet and stakeholders
on Wednesday the president looks forward
to hosting the U.S Africa leaders Summit
this Summit will underscore the value
the United States places on our
collaboration with Africa on the most
pressing Global challenges and
opportunities as well as on the Biden
administration's commitment to
revitalizing Global Partnerships and
alliances we expect to engage a wide
range of African and U.S stakeholders to
illustrate the breadth and the depth of
American Partnerships with African
governments businesses civil civil
society and citizens Partnerships based
on dialogue that harness the creative
the creativity of the peoples of our
peoples in the morning the president
will deliver remarks at the U.S Africa
business Forum later in the day he will
host a small group multilateral meeting
with leaders in the evening the
president will host the U.S Africa
leaders Summit dinner in the East room
the president will also observe the 10th
anniversary since the tragic Sandy Hook
shooting we will have more details on
that next week on Thursday the president
will continue his participation in the
Africa's leaders Summit he will
participate in the leaders success
session on partnering on the Africa
Union's agenda 2063 the continent's
Strategic framework for inclusive and
sustainable development based on
Pan-Africa Africa
Unity self-determination Freedom
progress Collective Prosperity
afterwards he will participate in a
family photo with the leaders in the
afternoon the president will participate
in the leaders session on promoting food
security and Food Systems resilience and
then on Friday the president will head
to Wilmington he will remain there over
the weekend with that it's all yours
basically
um did the president get a heads up from
Senator Cinema in advance of her
announcement this morning that she would
re-registered
so I will say this uh as always we do
not uh discuss private conversations
that we have with members of Congress
don't have anything else to share
outside of that but we are just not
going to share any private conversations
that we have accomplished could you talk
about the president's reaction was he
surprised well I put out a statement and
that as you know I speak for the
president of the United States uh so he
sees and we see Senator Cinema as a key
partner on some of the most historic
pieces of legislation that you all have
covered in this Administration when you
look at the past 20 months from the
American Rescue pan plan to the
bipartisan infrastructure law to the
inflation reduction act to the respect
for Marriage Act from the also The Pact
act all of these pieces of legislation
have been historic and we have partnered
with uh Senate Senator Cinema and so
look we understand her decision uh to
register it as an independent in Arizona
the way we see it and understand it it
does not change the new Democratic
majority control of the Senate and we
have every reason to expect that we will
continue to work with her successfully
and on a different topic yesterday's
prisoners swap does the president of the
deal that was struck by his
administration with the Russian
Administration was pretty Britney why it
was a fair one that was a fair
Arrangement look and what I've talked
about this uh yesterday as well uh
the here's the way that we have seen
this uh you know when you talk about
Fair uh Brittany Greiner is an American
citizen who was being held unjustly she
was being held unjustly uh under
intolerable circumstances that was what
was happening uh to Brittany Greiner and
so that means something to the president
uh he believes uh you know the when you
have an American passport it means
something and so he wanted to do
everything that he could uh to make sure
that he brought her home and we were
presented with an option as you know
we've laid this out you've heard from my
NSC colleagues as well where it was
either Brittany or no one that was the
option that we were given and so the
president wanted to keep his his uh
promise in making sure that he brings
American citizens home who are being
wrongfully detained abroad that is a
promise that his administration is
continuing to continue to fight for and
so that's what you saw these saw the
same action that he took with Trevor
Reed he took with Brittany Greiner and
others almost a dozen other other
wrongfully detained Americans have come
home under his administration and he is
going to continue to work very hard in
his administration to work very hard to
bring Paul Whelan home is that Pharaoh
or not
the way that we see it is that this was
an opportunity to bring an American home
that's how we saw the deal that was
presented to us and what was what was
occurring is in the past week or two we
saw that from the Russians were were
willing to release Brittany Greiner for
Mr boo that was what was presented to us
they were not willing uh to uh and I
said this yesterday to negotiate in good
faith for Paul Whelan and so it was
either
Brittany Greiner one American or no
American and so that's how we see the
negotiation that was presented in front
of us and that's the very difficult
decision that the president had to make
and we were able to bring her home
safely
okay I'm sorry I was gonna go ahead okay
I understand you're not going to detail
private conversations but just to be
clear was the White House given a heads
up that the senator Cinema was going I'm
just not going to go into the details
I'm just not going to go into details on
any private conversation that we have
I'm just not going to go into details or
lay out any private conversations that
we have with Congress that's something
that we normally do just not going to do
that but that's just a private
conversation I'm not I'm Mary I'm just
not going to go into details on this
well let me try this then just two days
ago you said that warnock's win gave you
a little bit more Breathing Room a
little bit more ability to deliver for
the American people does Cinema's
decision to leave the party take away
some of that breathing room look as I
said uh and I and I put out a statement
on this as you all know as I said that
we see we understand Senator Cinema's
decision to register as an independent
the way that we see it it does not
change uh the majority or it doesn't
change uh the complexion of what the
demo Democratic majority is going to
look like in the Senate
continue to work successfully with
Cinema where does that expectation come
from because she has voted with the
president 93 of the time because she has
worked with us on key priorities of this
Administration we think about his
Economic Policy I just laid out all of
the different historic pieces of
legislation that we have been able to
get done and she has played a key role
in that when you think about the chips
and science act when you think about the
bipartisan infrastructure law those are
pieces of legislation there are other
there's other long list of other things
that she's worked with us on that's 93
and so we think that partnership will
continue we do not see a change in our
Democratic majority as it relates to the
Senate so we are very confident
I'm gonna call actually on Alex in the
back because of what occurred yesterday
I know Brett is not here but want to
give you an opportunity to ask a
question
I wanted to ask about if the president
has spoken with any gun violence
prevention Advocates or victims families
ahead of the Sandy Hook anniversary and
also if he has any plans to talk to
lawmakers next week about his call for
assault weapons ban
um I don't have anything to preview at
this time on any calls that the
president might might make or will make
the president has talked about Sandy
Hook being the worst day in his in his
eight years as vice president and you
can expect him to mark this sad day next
week as I laid out in the week ahead on
Wednesday as you all saw the president
join survivors and families impacted by
gun violence to deliver remarks at the
10th Annual National vigil for all
victims of gun violence organized by the
Newton action Alliance the vigil was a
service of mourning and loving
remembrance for all who have fallen
victim to the ongoing epidemic of gun
violence in America and as you all know
the president has done more than speak
about gun violence he's actually taken
action he fought relentlessly to take
action as well he has done more
executive taking more executive action
at this time in his presidency than any
other president and so look and let's
not forget he signed the most
significant gun safety legislation in 30
years this summer but he feels that is
not enough and we need to do more and so
he continues to call for the assault
weapons ban he did that on that day on
Wednesday when he uh when he was there
with families and friends speaking of of
this moment and he's never going to stop
showing up and speaking out and I have
said this before he believes his role as
president is to make sure that we
continue to put this continue to push
this into the dialogue so making sure
that the American people understand how
important it is to talk about getting
the assault weapons ban
Chris thank you so much I want to follow
up on Mary's question when she asked you
why you feel confident that you'll be
able to continue to work with Senator
Cinema successful and you studied her
correctly but just to put a fine point
on it has the administration been given
assurances by anyone within the
Senator's office or the senator herself
that she is going to continue to work
with you I'm just not going to divulge
or speak to any private conversations
that we have with members of Congress
that is something that is not unusual
that's something that I've said many
times before understand the question
what I am saying is her actions speak to
what we're trying to lay out here right
93 that she's voted uh she's voted with
the president over the last 20 months
I've listed out the historic pieces of
legislation that she has been played a
significant role that she's played a key
partner role with us and so and you know
we don't see a change in the Democratic
majority with her deciding to uh to
register as an independent do you expect
her to caucus with
with uh look I we don't see a change in
the Democratic majority uh and so we see
this as a decision that she has made but
we do not see a change in our Democratic
majority let me ask you this way and
then I do have one
um on Brittany Greiner does Sutter
Cinema have the support of the president
in this decision and moving forward into
2024. so cannot speak to 2024 I'm
covered by the Hatch Act and as far as I
understand it she hasn't announced her
plans for 2024 uh yet so I just not
something that I'm going to speak to for
the president right now oh absolutely
decision when we see her as a key
partner we don't we understand her
decision to register as an independent
let me ask you about something that
Vladimir Putin said today as you know he
held that press conference and he said
more prisoner swaps may occur between
the U.S and Russia he said quote
everything is possible what does the U.S
make of that what does the
administration hear in those words so
we're just not going to talk about uh
any ongoing diplomatic conversations
we've been very clear that we want the
American people to know that their
Safety and Security is among our highest
priority uh when when it comes to
aggressively doing everything that we
can to bring Americans home who are
being wrongfully detained bringing them
home safely but not going to get into
any diplomatic conversations from here
[Music]
Biden spoken to her or does he plan to
so don't have any um any calls to
preview as you know as you know the
president spoke with her Brittany
Greiner yesterday morning in the in the
seven o'clock eight o'clock hour right
before he came out to speak to all of
you and to give the announcement and in
the room was her wife and the vice
president and and Jake Sullivan and also
the Secretary of State and you we've
also we've already read out what uh what
that conversation was like I do want to
give a little bit more of a little bit
more information on where we are this
morning we can confirm as you all know
that Brittany Greiner arrived at Saint
at Joint Base San Antonio Fort Sam
Houston early this morning she has been
reunited with her wife shirelle U.S
officials who met her on the ground said
she was in very good spirits appears to
be in good health she was immediately
taken to Brook Army Medical Center where
she is being offered a range of Support
options following her time detained in
Russia
but next what I can tell you is where
she is currently today every individual
is different and those decisions are up
to them and their families they'll take
as much time as they need what we can
say typically upon arrival people are
offered a wide range of additional
support including full medical checkup a
mental health checkup and additional
means of support all of this is
voluntary so it is up to to her and her
family can you confirm the report that
Russia wanted the vatam krasikov who is
a Russian assassin being held in Germany
in exchange for hallway land so I cannot
go into any specifics or any
negotiations information from here as
you know we are working very hard to
secure Paul's return and so don't want
to get don't want to get ahead of what's
currently happening and I just want to
leave it there okay did the U.S have any
conversations with a third party
when they were negotiating the prisoner
swap I'm just not going to get into
specifics on any of the negotiations
what I can tell you was that we realized
and I think I said this moment ago we
realized about a week or two ago that
Russia was willing to do a negotiation
to release Brittany Greiner and that was
uh Brittany Greiner for Mr Boot and
that's what they offered they were not
they were not negotiating in good faith
when it came to Paul they categorized
him very differently and we've talked
about that unfortunately in an
illegitimate illegitimate charges that
they levied against Paul and so at this
at this time we were not able to um we
were not able to secure his release I
don't want to get into any specifics
about negotiations as we continue to
have those conversations to secure Paul
just one more
one up
in order to get an American bag is the
U.S only willing to swap a Russian
national or would it consider trying to
work with another country to get someone
else I get your question and I
understand I just cannot get into what
we will or will not do any of the
negotiations we have Americans out there
who are wrongfully detained being held
hostage and we want to make sure that we
get them home safely and negotiating
from here or giving in information on
the internal mechanics of process I
certainly would not be be prudent
[Music]
thanks crane um China is using its
covered zero restrictions I'm wondering
if you could talk about whether it's
something at the White House
ports or doesn't and specifically how
you see a plane out for us manufacturing
that has operations in China if you
think it will sort of improve Supply
chains because there will be less
restrictions on workers or is there
concern both medical and economic about
uh if there are wide scale outbreaks of
covet and China now so any uh PR any
policies of the PRC I'm certainly not
going to comment about them from here
what we have been very clear about is
China's coveted policy is not a policy
we are pursuing here in the United
States we are focused on what works like
encouraging Americans to get their
updated vaccine which we try to do as
often as we can from here and also just
more broadly in the administration and
making testing and treatment easily
accessible that is our that is our going
to be our Focus we're just not going to
comment on prc's policies and then Fox
Business had a report today that Bank of
America CEO Brian Moynihan is on a short
list to replace yelling if and when she
decides to leave the administration
wondering if you could comment on that
so as secretary yellin said herself just
last month she has no plans to leave it
seems to be that report to us seems to
be pure speculation
I'm gonna go okay
I have two questions the first one is
first I thought you were going to talk
to me in French I was gonna be like oh
gosh
but my mom's now watching
uh first thing is on the statement that
came out today about Canada and the U.S
taking
um coordinated act as a sanctioned
against Iranian officials
um connected to Human Rights abuse I'm
trying to figure out why this
coordination with Canada and this is
very uh instant first of all it's good
to see you it's been a while a long time
so I know I made a joke but it is good
to see you so I just want to say at the
top the United States is committed to
supporting the Iranian people and
imposing costs on those responsible for
the brutal Crackdown we continue to
coordinate with allies and partners and
find ways to confront Iran's human
rights abuses both in public and also in
private The Joint U.S Canada statement
today is an example of this effort we
took coordinated sanctions against
actions pardon me today against Iranian
officials connected to Human Rights
abuses including those committed as part
committed as part of the ongoing brutal
Crackdown aimed at denying the Iranian
people their human rights and their
fundamental freedoms their fundamental
rights and so we'll continue to support
the Iranian people I can't speak to you
know Canada you would have to speak to
their government as I'm sure you do
often but I can't speak to different
countries reasoning for their own
reasoning for taking action but clearly
this is an important action that shows
support for the Iranian people as we're
seeing this truly brutal Crackdown on
the civilians there thank you well my
other question is on the uh next week's
Summit the African leader Summit uh I'm
just I mean we're going to get into
details but I'm trying to figure out how
much do the the Chinese intense economic
involvement and the Russian through
Wagner military involvement is playing a
role in the president's willingness to
engage even more intensely with them
years what I can say our Focus next week
is going to be on Africa that's going to
be the focus of the summit this Summit
is an opportunity to deepen the many
Partnerships we have on the African
continent we will focus on our efforts
to strengthen these partnership across
wide range of sectors spanning from
businesses to health to peace and
security but our Focus will be on Africa
next week
can you provide any updates on what the
president is doing to push forward the
government spending bill
so look we I've talked about this many
times and we believe you know getting
the government funding uh done is
critical and it's going to be important
and this is something that we encourage
uh and continue to talk to Congress
about getting this done I talked about
how Shalonda young is leading certainly
leading that effort our OMB director and
she knows how to get a bipartisan deals
uh done here and look we were able to
get government funding done in a
bipartisan way last year we believe it
should be done in a bipartisan way this
year there is enough time to get this
done we are talking about critical uh
resources that the American people need
when you think about public health
public education our national security
these are all incredibly important and
it should be done in a bipartisan way
and there's enough time to get that get
that moving and as families are facing
Rising school lunch debt can you also
provide provide an update as to what the
president is doing to push forward
preschool meals for all so the president
as you've heard him say is proud that
his American Rescue plan provided
additional emergency food and nutrition
assistant for those in need building on
our 60 million dollar investment in farm
to school initiatives our national
strategy on Hunger nutrition and health
which we released in September includes
a provision on creating a path to free
health School meals for all children as
a first step in reaching this goal the
administration is committed to working
with Congress to expand access to
healthy free School meals to an
additional 9 million kids over the next
decade but obviously this has been a
priority for this presence since the
beginning of his administration
Korean uh just a follow-up on Iran
um and human rights Iran just accepted a
man for his involvement in the
anti-government protests other detainees
also face the possibility of the death
penalty related to the protests can you
speak more specifically on those
instances so we denounce these Draconian
sentences uh in the strongest terms
these sentences are meant to intimidate
people and suppress this dissent and so
they will not work and and iranian's
Leadership continues its violent
Crackdown as they do that on Peaceful
protesters they should know that the
world is watching it just talked about a
letter uh that that was signed by our
allies uh calling calling uh uh really
calling that out continuing to do that
so the United States is committing to
supporting the Iranian people and
imposing costs on those responsible for
the brutal Crackdown just today again we
announced the sanctions to hold Iran
accountable for human rights abuses we
continue to coordinate with allies and
partners and find ways to confront
Iran's human rights abuses both again as
I said earlier in public and in private
we will stand with Iranian civilians as
they are fighting for their basic
Freedom their their basic human rights
and we will continue to denounce that
okay and another question on Saudi
please despite President Biden plan to
follow through with a statement that
there will be consequences on Saudi
Arabia following their oil production
Cuts or is the understanding now that
gas prices have stabilized so perhaps
it's not as urgent for those
consequences to happen and just more
broadly speaking does the growing ties
between Saudi and China does that play a
role in the administration's
reassessment of relations with Saudis
that were promised to us so there's a
couple of things there kind of laid out
a couple of items that I'll touch on so
look the gas prices that we're seeing
currently that are going down is because
of the work that this president has done
is because he took historic action to
tap into the Strategic petroleum reserve
and because of those actions we're
seeing prices go down so I want to be
very very clear on that so as far as the
relationship the review that you're
asking me about we are assessing a
relations with Saudi Arabia
methodolically and strategically as we
have done over the last last uh you know
80 years of this relationship in a
bipartisan way and it's uh it's we're
going to do this in line with what's in
our interest and we will judge the way
forward based on their actions as well
as our ongoing consultations with
partners and allies and also the new
Congress that is going to be before us
very soon and the Saudis as well don't
have anything more to share but again
remember this is an 80 as you know in 80
year history and as we have re-evaluated
over the course of those eight decades
in a bipartisan way and that's how we're
looking to move forward really quickly
last one on Taiwan can you comment on
the timing of the 425 Million Dollar Arm
sales with Taiwan earlier this week
which happened on the same day that the
president went to Arizona to visit the
tsmc plant which is of course part of
the effort to get ahead of the Strategic
rivalry with China is there any kind of
message in here that these two events
happen on the same day so there's no
connection I can say pretty
affirmatively there's no connection
there this was a package of upgrades on
pre-existing sale I think we've talked
about that here before in the in in the
briefing room we continue to support
taiwan's self-defense consistent with
our long-standing One China policy so no
change there okay
former vice president of the Eco Health
Alliance has a new book out and he says
that he's convinced that covid-19 leaked
from Lab to my knowledge he hasn't
produced any direct evidence but he
speculates that a risky U.S funded
research calls the pandemic does the US
government have a response to that so I
would refer you to the NIH on that but a
couple of things and Eco Health as well
for specifics here on the question that
you have but we do not know the origins
as you know of covid because of the of
China's lack of transparency as I've
said before uh you know this is
something we including the president
have pressed China on repeatedly NIH has
exhaustively communicated the oversight
of its scientific work and its purpose
to ensure pandemic preparedness it quite
it's quite wonky as you know and so
again I would refer you to NIH again
it's very in-depth and this is that's
the place that I would refer you to get
more specifics just a very brief
follow-up before turning to Twitter
Dr fauci's agency recently resumed
funding for the ecohealth alliance is
there any concern about that given its
past risky risky research in Wuhan and
it if you're not able to speak to that I
was wondering if you could perhaps
invite Dr fauci back here to take some
more questions I would refer you to NIH
they would provide you with the
information directly so I'll just leave
that there but on Twitter Elon Musk this
week fired the former FBI general
counsel Jim Baker who was serving as a
top Twitter lawyer musk alleges that he
may have been involved with
counterbanding his attempts at
transparency and I was wondering if
anyone in the Bible Administration was
in touch with Baker either regarding
moderation decisions that critics called
political censorship or regarding his
transparency efforts recently so it's up
to private companies to make these types
of decisions we were not involved I can
say that we were not involved and as
I've said several times this week
already we've talked we've had this
conversation many times in this briefing
room just the past couple of days uh you
know of course it's up to these
companies to make their own decisions
about the content on their platform and
to ensure content flows there on
standards and on their own standards and
policies don't have anything more to
share but on the not involved not
involved in uh
speaking with Baker about this
transparency effort by mosque is that
what you're saying that the Bible
Administration wasn't involved we're
just we're just not involved just
answering a question we were not
involved okay
um I think probably process this
question to some degree but the official
commutation order for Victor Booth was
signed by the president on December 2nd
for everything actually transpired why
if I just did that mean that the deal
was done then or you did it in
preparation for a deal how does that
actually work so as I've stated before
um well you just stated it uh that uh
about the clemency look
we knew about a week or two ago that
there was going to be a deal for uh
Brittany Greiner and that was what the
Russians had presented to us and they
wanted the deal right the to secure her
return was uh Mr boot for uh uh Brittany
Mr boot for Brittany Greiner and so that
was the deal that we was presented to us
and that's how we move forward because
we wanted to make sure we brought one
American home it was either no American
or one American and so that that process
was about a week or two ago I can't go
into details specifics on the five days
or when things were signed I don't have
that information to provide for you at
this time but we learned that about over
the last week a week or two ago a
preparatory nothing was Final until
Brittany Greiner was in the custody yeah
you know
um I kind of laid out kind of the
process yesterday or how that all worked
uh don't have that in front of me to
share with you at this time but what I
can say is the past week or two we've we
learned from uh from the from the
Russians that they were willing uh to uh
to release Brittany Greiner for Mr boot
uh and we tried throughout the past
several months as you know the past six
months since we heard uh from secretary
blinken back in July saying that we were
in intensive conversation uh to uh to
get to get Brittany home to get Paul
Whalen home and every uh in every
conversation over the last several
months we worked very hard to get the
both of them home that was always a
priority and again it wasn't until very
recently that we learned that they were
only willing to make it make a an
arrangement for Brittany Greiner and
Paul Whalen as I've stated many times
before was just seen differently uh in a
illegitimate way way and so the
president wanted to make sure we brought
we brought an American home and that's
what we saw yesterday uh in terms of
legislative very much and the lame Ducks
out right now but as the last week
either changed or
deep planning for the next Congress
legislatively how you guys approach the
next Congress or was it shifted At All
by what happened what happened this
morning yes no not at all I mean and
that's that's the point that I'm trying
to make here you know you have a uh you
have someone Senator Cinema who has uh
you know voted with the president 93 of
the time on key important historic
pieces of legislation and I listed them
out uh
um earlier I'm not going to bore you by
doing that again but they were important
pieces of legislation that you all
covered and we've talked about in this
briefing room and so we do not see we
understand why she would want to
register as an independent but we do not
see the Democratic majority changing
with this decision that she's made
just want to ask you on the oil price
Camp so there's 20 oil Laden tankers Now
sort of stuck trying to get out of the
Black Sea into the Turkish Turkish
Straits I know that treasury officials
have been in touch with Turkish
officials on this
um you know are you looking at
escalating that conversation you know to
a higher level are you frustrated with
turkey's reluctance to back away from
this
rule somebody's having a good time
so as you said we've been in touch with
turkey about how the price cap only
applies to Russian oil and explained
that the cap doesn't necessarily
necessitate necessitate additional
checks on ships passing through Turkish
Waters our understanding is that
virtually all of the delayed tankers are
not carrying oil from Russia and are not
affected by the cap so turkey has made
clear they they share our interest in a
well supplied market and allowing a
Seabourn oil to Transit the transit the
the Turkish Straits they have made clear
their goal is to resolve this issue as
quickly as possible and so again we've
been we've been in touch with turkey and
this is uh how we how we're moving
forward
seem to be resolved at all I mean
there's 28 tankers now and now on top of
it you know you've got the Turkish
officials saying they they don't see any
reason to rescind that rule well our in
our conversation uh they they want to
resolve this issue and we are again
having those conversations with turkey
uh and we feel like we're going to get
into a place where this will get
resolved okay
[Music]
okay
avoid
um you know having to settle below the
cap
you know are you at any in any way sort
of considering that this oil price cap
was not a success or will not be a
success because of these various
responses look the we're not surprised
by Putin's reaction and response and
what Russia is saying look the price the
price will lock in a discount on Russian
oil especially in light of the hundred
dollar per barrel they earned just a few
months ago and it can be adjusted over
time to prevent Russia from further
profiteering from its war and we see
this as an opportunity this is an
unprecedented action demonstrates the
unity of the United States and our
allies and partners so uh again you know
I'm not going to be when it comes to you
know slowing limiting their flow we're
not in the business of responding to a
hypothetical as well but wanted to lay
out how we see this process moving
forward and we don't and we don't know
what will happen but as we have said we
are focused on limiting Putin's ability
ability to profit from rising prices to
fund his illegal War while promoting
stable stable Global energy markets this
is not about this is not about Russian
oil of the market this is about the cap
the cap at this level maintains clear
incentives for Russia to continue
exporting and we believe that it should
can I just ask you a domestic question
so Maxwell for us was denied um
[Music]
department or an application because of
really bad credit
um are you I know that you've looked at
housing inequities and problems facing
people of color in terms of getting
housing and just fairness in the housing
market
this practice of you know requiring
credit applications and then fees that
carry a fee seems to be something that's
happening all over the country is there
anything that the White House or the
divided Administration can do to curb
what you know seems to be a predatory
practice in some cases where people are
basically you know that in order to even
get a chance of getting an apartment in
this very tight and difficult housing
market you have to pay the money up
front so with the president and the
administration understands that
Americans are struggling uh with a high
cost of housing that is something that
we have seen throughout these past
several years and that's why the
president released his housing Supply
action plan that we have talked about
and it's to ease the thought that burden
that burden of housing costs over time
by using a mix of administrative and
legislative actions to boost the supply
of quality housing in every Community
just last month the White House hosted a
range of tenants and tenant advocates
for listening sessions along with
federal agencies and we'll have more to
to more conversations like these and
we'll add uh you know we'll we'll to add
the topics that you're just laying out
but again that's why the president took
initiative with his plan I've talked
about the different specifics of the
plan and how it's going to help folks
who feel that burden because we also
understand the housing costs again is is
one of the things that has a big effect
on people's lives and livelihoods so
this is a priority for this
Administration
great um I wanted to ask an earlier
Russia question another way
um so when Putin says that nothing is
off the table with future prisoner swaps
what in your view is the best way for
the American people who may just be
turning into this issue based on what
happened with Brittany Greiner to
actually think about what Putin is
saying should it be seen as a
substantive offer to engage should it be
viewed with skepticism should it
heighten hopes that Paul Whalen could be
brought home I'm wondering if you can
just set expectations based on the
current state of play between our two
countries so I can say this and the
president said this yesterday he is
committed to getting Paul wheelan home
that is a commitment that he has made to
his family and that is the commitment
that he's made to the American people
and more broadly speaking the president
since the beginning of his
administration has said that his one of
his top priorities is making sure that
all Americans who are who are being
wrongfully detained and held hostage are
brought home uh and you know we have
seen this multiple times throughout this
past 20 months again Trevor Reed we saw
in April the president bring home
Brittany Greiner clearly yesterday and
about 12 other
American citizens and so the president's
going to stay committed to that I'm not
going to get into what President Putin
says or not say or I'm just not going to
get into his head that's not something
that we do from here what I will say is
that we are going to continue to
negotiate in good faith to get Paul home
care to follow up from the other day on
the ndaa the house has now passed this
legislation it does rescind the military
vaccine mandate which made clear the
president does not agree with uh will
the president sign this legislation or
veto it again I'm just not going to get
ahead of the president this is something
that the president decides on uh we've
been very clear will we stand on the
vaccine mandates and we we've said it
many times before you know republicans
in Congress have decided that they'd
rather fight against the health and
well-being of our troops than protect
them and we think that it's a mistake uh
look uh not gonna again not going to get
ahead of the any final votes that may
occur you talked about the house every
year the ndaa has some Provisions we
support and some we don't so the
president will judge this in its
entirety I know again I noted that that
the house is moving on this but I'm just
not going to get of of any decision that
the president's going to make not yet I
I just haven't I have not spoken to him
about this and so I'm just not going to
get ahead of him
[Music]
was uh I don't have uh I don't have a
the last time that they spoke um so
don't have anything to share with you at
this time on that while he was in
Arizona he called her quote a tremendous
advocate for the people of Arizona and a
leader and so many issues important to
this state end quote does he regret
making that statement which none of you
as an endorsement
I I mean he says this about many uh
Congressional members when he visits a
state I've I've been on many trips with
him you've been on trips with him where
he says that he thanks them for the
passport to their state and he actually
talks about the work that he's done uh
with that uh congressperson or Senator
uh in in Washington DC that is very very
common uh you can look at almost any
every speech that he's made while he's
visited the state and he talks about and
lists uh how these Congressional members
and Senators house members have he's
worked with them to deliver whether it's
the bipartisan infrastructure
legislation whether it's the American
Rescue plan uh whether it is uh the
inflation reduction act or all so that
is not uncommon he does that very
regularly I would say every time he goes
to a state he lifts up the Congressional
members who who are who are you know who
represent that state and on another
topic this is the point Administration I
think to adjust some point where people
do start thinking about leaving have any
members of the president's cabinet
informed him of a decision to leave in
the next few months yeah as far as I
know no
has the U.S reached out directly to
Syria to seek Austin tice's release his
family issued a statement saying the NSC
has failed to meet with the syrians to
work with them look you know I I don't
want to get again trying to be very
careful here not going to get into any
negotiations or personal conversations
that we may be having with uh with the
wrongfully detained or someone who is
being held abroad we want to be very
careful here I don't want to get into
diplomatic diplomatic discussions what I
will say is that this President is
committed as I've said many times as he
has said to to do everything that he
possibly can to bring home Americans who
are wrongfully detained and held hostage
and that is a commitment that you have
seen he you know he has
you know promised and kept over the past
several months and following up from
earlier in the week do you know if the
president has counted the votes to
determine if he will seek an assault
weapons ban during the land dog don't
have anything more to share on beyond
what I said a couple days ago I just
don't I haven't I haven't uh I don't
have an update for you at this time
hey screen on the on the economy
um so we saw that we saw the producer
price index come down a bit but it's
still above seven percent um the Federal
Reserve chairman says that core
inflation may be moving sideways we get
a CPI inflation reading again next week
um so if Americans don't see significant
progress on inflation does that mean the
inflation reduction act early next year
hasn't worked well it okay let's step
back for a second so near-term inflation
expectation fell this month so that's
important we saw that in the data so
it's important to call out uh the
producer uh the producer pricing deck
Rose at its slowest annual rate since
May 2021 so that is data points that we
saw uh in in the index today Americans
are beginning to see a much needed break
in inflation but we have more work to do
and so gas prices have fallen about a
dollar seventy cents since June and are
lower than they were a year ago before
Putin's War that's because of the work
that this president has done to bring
gas prices down to deal with an issue
that matters to the American people when
we look at the economy which is
inflation and and cost so millions of
Americans shopping for a health
insurance plans continue to save 800 per
year thanks to the inflation reduction
act so yes it's been beneficial and we
see that it is working and in six weeks
President Biden plan to bring down
prescription drugs prescription drug
prices and energy costs goes into effect
and that's going to matter for the
American people as they think about when
they sit around their kitchen table you
hear the president talk about this at
the end of the month trying to figure
out how are they going to pay for items
in their house and these what I just
listed out or in their lives is going to
matter lowering costs health care costs
lowering energy costs we're all already
seeing that it's going to have a real
effect on American families and so I
will leave it there the inflation before
the midterms you told me that the
inflation reduction act should bring
down inflation early next year so if it
doesn't do that significantly is that
scene first of all you're that's a bunch
of hypotheticals that you're asking me
I'm what I laid out was something that
economists said by looking at the
inflation reduction act by examining it
and no understanding what it's going to
do for the American people you're
bringing up a hypothetical what I said
was again what we what was uh what was
the analysis that was done by economists
and I just laid out also how we see uh
the inflation reduction it's actually
going to help the American people and
that matters and you know uh you know I
have to say Ed and just going back to
the past several months as well look the
inflation reduction Act was a piece of
legislation that was signed by the
president that was only passed by
democrats and what you saw from
Republican officials over the past
several months is how they wanted to get
rid of it because they were upset about
social social security they wanted to
put Medicare on the chopping block and
they have no plan to lowering costs so
what you're seeing from this
Administration what you're seeing from
this president what you're seeing from
Democrats in DC in Congress is that they
are taking action to lower costs for the
American people and that matters and
that's what we're going to continue to
do I'm
an end of the year housekeeping question
following up on what I think Karen was
asking about
the house is already voted on the ndaa
the Senate uh most likely take it up
this week
did the Senate expect to know what the
position of the president is on the bill
before they vote on it I mean we've been
very clear when I've been asked about
the vaccine mandate we thought that that
was a mistake uh you know and it wasn't
just from the president it was also from
uh you we the the Senate and Congress
received a letter from secretary Austin
saying how important have they he
believed how important the vaccine
mandate was what I'm saying is we want
to look at and the president and not
just this President other presidents
have been able to judge the package in
its entirety and so that's what we're
looking to do uh and uh but we're also
going to be very vocal as we have been
on what happened and occurred with the
vaccine mandate in the ndaa on another
end of the year item obviously there's
the spending package which was discussed
earlier is there anything else beyond
the spending package in the ndaa that is
on the list that the president has for
things that he would like uh the the
house to accomplish before control turns
over to the Republicans in January well
we've we've actually laid that laid that
out a couple of times
um you know we we believe that the
president believes that we should get
the government funded as I just
mentioned including what we need to
respond to the disasters uh continue to
defend democracy in Ukraine and fight
and fight new covet variants we're gonna
we're gonna sign the marriage he's going
to sign the marriage equality act which
is something clearly that the president
supported and so look we're going to
continue to to work with Congress uh and
continue to encourage Congress to get
this stuff done he also believes we
should pass the Electoral Reform Act he
believes we should pass the defense
authorization bill right and that the
permitting bill should be also something
that we should move forward with so we
kind of listed out some of the things
that are important we hope to finish
confirming the judicial nominees the
president made earlier this year so
those are just a few of those items that
I've listed out before that we are
certainly focused on
all right all right thanks everybody
have a great weekend